hey folks I'm Curtin Davina and for
today's play for all in view we have two
very special guests from the brilliant
studio arcane joining me today is dingo
bacopa and sebastian mattone thank you
both for being here
deeply deeply deeply honored to have you
in this this video presence we just got
our first really good in-depth look just
a few weeks ago but let's just start the
chat with what is death dupe and I'll
throw this to you digger this is it's a
first person action game first person
shooter about two rival assassins that
are locked in a time loop it's all next
game it's a game that we are quite
passionate about you might get some of
that energy in things like your trailers
or artwork etcetera etcetera a lot of
energy is going into it because it's a
it's a game where we wanted to try some
new things you know shake things a
little bit so that's why we have this
new world these new characters but yes
it's the next game game
I personally adore the unanswered
questions that I'm getting from the
trailer because it's I wanna i want to
ask like what is black reef is called a
prisoner here why is he in this loop but
those are all things that i would kind
of want to save it for that moment but
lots of questions but i want to ask the
right one of course without revealing
anything it's a challenge in a way when
you're making a game and you want to
preserve some mystery but still show how
cool it is and share that enthusiasm
that you have you know with the fans
with everyone there is a little bit of
what what should we say what should we
show it's you know it's it's almost a
game in itself to solve that that riddle
i think we're excited by that value
we're excited by the mystery of it
and the strong concepts that we can put
in front of everyone without ruining it
and until now we're pretty happy about
that
our cane games have such a distinctive
aesthetic look and feel that have so
much conceptual world building within it
and most of the time those we the
players have to seek it out and have to
find it to truly understand what the
full scope of what's happening in
sebastian for you as an art director
going off something like dishonored just
one or two in this very European almost
you know semi gothic vibe to what feels
like a death loop of Funkadelic 70s 5
what is what is that transition like and
what was the inspirations that led to
that group in the sense that it's not
true it was in can occur at the edge of
the world and this time we are not in
the same world that we are regarding the
60s helped believe you know what's the
past of this place how can we do
something really cool with the mystery
applied we want to inject in the game so
that's always the same philosophy of
bringing ideas to the game but also how
we us as a team we try to work this out
and make it really cool for the fans of
the new audience because we also target
you know a large audience to grow the
audience with this town you know some of
the guns are in a trailer like there was
these two pistols that had this there
will like glittered almost like it
jammed up and it's just like those
little touches of what you know of
making the guns feel all encompassing in
this thing that got me just so excited
and hyped to be using something that I'm
familiar with like a pistol is something
that looks distinctly cool and like tied
to that universe in that game one of the
things we excited was to make our own
versions of things that are even closer
to us culturally
then you know a Victorian sword your
vest for instance time so now we have
coats who is like an extraordinary
assassin with a badass you know leather
jacket and all those concepts are indeed
more accessible but it's still a lot of
fun to find our own twist and be unhappy
about 100 version of that gun you
mentioned and you know the 101 version
you were like okay this is totally it
yeah it's always there is always this
thing when you're doing something a bit
crazy and I really admire Sebastian his
team for this you know consistency the
one thing that's kind of unique where
our distinct is the concept of death in
this game the die die again what can you
tell me about that and how its what that
was like
implementing death as what feels like a
core feature of the game to be fair it's
it goes beyond depth death sorry it's
really about the loop it's all tied into
the time because whether you die or not
you know the day will restart and so
it's really this it's really all
starting from the time from the time
loop that is central part of the game
it's a character in itself and this of
course is a part of its death of you
know leave your enemies because of
course death that doesn't have the same
meaning in a place where everyone just
comes back the next day it's it's really
something where we were trying to make
death of the death of the player here
more as a step towards success
you know colt is this character who is
very stubborn he has a goal he's a she
has his resolved you say I think but
also every step he makes whether it
results in dying or not he's learning
new things that's really something we
to make is a game well knowledge is
power absolutely Sebastian dinger
mentioned how our King games usually
kind of build these more expansive
environments to explore when in this
case it's kind of different because it's
an environment you'll be going through
over and over and over again from an art
direction standpoint was there a
conscious change in how you may be
looked at designing what the world
looked like knowing that the player
would have to be repeating certain areas
again and again and again yeah that's a
good comment it's not it's very less
linear because you visit the way you
want and you see different period of
time of the same location so the our
challenge is to build something when
interesting in term of fashions and
which will create greater expense for
the player plus we have some stuff I
cannot talk about but that will change
things so you know I think you look but
it's not boring you know you discover
stuff that are really cool maybe
sometimes I even myself because I'm not
ready deep into walking the math on that
discover stuff during a review I'm like
wow this is really cool but visually
it's really do we want something where
the player is immersed into something it
doesn't in the real life so that's why
we move to the time pad so it doesn't
reflect reality and it's very less
boring that that although on the paper
at the beginning you know you have ideas
and people are like okay let's see
example the glitter of thing we have
many ingredients that you want to know
you you're like okay 60s I knew it now
because I with so many books and watch
movies and I'm moving from then maybe
think out more in into an on-chip stuff
and I'm like okay let's exist I feel
that it's great etc and you hope you you
get a good whisk recite yeah and so
people are like oh I'm sure and then
when it comes to fast-forward to the
river try up the place find all the
our last show and you see direction of
people like that's so cool you know and
you're like ah when I was I was good it
was a good idea
and it's more stuff like this you know
on every aspect of the game that makes
us really happy to to Pedro so one thing
also that's completely new to to the
archein formula that we've seen is
multiplayer and there's I know that the
so much of what makes these games the
immersive Sims is the ability to play
the way you want so how did you approach
putting a multiplayer in to death loop
while still trying to not break the what
it is that kind of defines your games
it's really about you know let's
challenge ourselves a number of things
and you know find the experiment and
find you know cool solutions to new
problems etc etc and yes it did of
course evolve a formula and this is
something we are not unfamiliar with
because all of our games since the
creation of arcane have you know
injected new DNA each time here is a fun
fact when it I think multiplayer in
dopamine to at least the the role of
Triana you know what's what we are doing
in this game is that cult is playing the
campaign he has his you know mission
about how to break the time loop he has
to piece together what's happening who
is who those people are etcetera etc and
then how to break this situation and
there is one element of chaos that is
not on a schedule and that is Julianne
she's a mysterious woman we don't
exactly know what she is about she has a
I would say a very strong and
larger-than-life character she's awesome
she's I mean I have to say hence
you know hats off to the narrative team
I love Giuliana she's a she's an
incredible villain at some point it
became well you know what would be cool
well what if she can be played by
another player actually so that she is
really unpredictable so that she should
so that we really cover the range of her
personality that is sometimes almost
friendly as a rival sometimes extremely
brutal and harsh and violent sometimes
trolling you sometimes trying to impress
you like this this really cool
relationship that is happening we said
well who is who would be best to role
play a fantastic character like that
then actually not even one player but a
multitude of persons all over the world
so it's it's a really big thing for this
project and yeah we're really excited
about it but most of all like with all
our games with we are excited by what
players will do with it I think he you
know it comes to immersion and and
allowing players to play how they want
it sounds captivating it the idea of
someone can play as you know go straight
shot go for the go for the story try to
solve what's happening is cold but then
there's that if they want to be a little
bit chaotic or at least twist things up
they can step out and play as Juliana
instead so they're still it still feels
like there's you know I know you want
players to play with creativity and I
think that and if it's self kind of
shows this distinction of you can change
your play styles on the fly and if you
don't want it you know necessarily go to
culture it so that's really fascinating
unfortunately that is all the time we
have today
I could probably keep talking I can
probably keep asking questions but we'll
save that for a lot of the mystery that
is gonna come when death lip is finally
out so throw this over to you folks
when is death loop coming out or when
what can you tell us about and when can
we get our hands on it so to see more ha
get your hands on it that's the secret
but the game
the game will reason the PS 5 and on PC
420 twins perfect all right well
Sebastian dinga thank you so much for
being here it's been a huge pleasure and
honor again I'm Curtin Davina thanks for
coming here for play for all stay tuned
to game spot for all the death of news
coming up see you later
[Music]
you
[Music]